Welcome to lesson five. In lesson five we're going to
talk about how to make your website communicate with, not just
with humans but also with other computers by building what
we call an API or Application Programming Interface, which is really
just a fancy way of saying instead of generating HTML
that we send to browsers that ultimately just get read by
humans, we're going to send data in formats XML or JSON
which are similar to html, but are designed to be read
by computers instead. In this lesson we're going to add a
feature to ASCIIChan, that will actually allow you to see where
users are submitting images from, using the Google maps API.
And in the homework for this lesson, we're going to be adding
the JSON output to your own blog. So if somebody
wanted to build a service that used some data from your
blog that you thought was important, they can actually write a
program to fetch your blog, manipulate the data however they like,
and then build their own web service on top of that, which is actually
how a lot of the internet works. So, let's go ahead and jump right in.